one of my favorite business models in
the world look at what everyone else is
doing do it in half the time if normally
it takes you 100 days to get the average
customer to win figure out how you can
do it in seven figure out how you can do
it in three figure out how you can do it
in 24 hours think about the difference
between the marketing agenty that signs
up a customer and says okay we're going
to start running your ads and uh it'll
take us about 60 days to get you spun up
and then you should start getting some
lead flop consider that with as soon as
the guy hangs up with the sales guy his
phone rings hey I just saw your ad now
that's obviously a super extreme example
on both sides well the closer you are to
that one even though the actual
deliverable is the same how much more
valuable is this one so much more
valuable